well so a lot of my books are actually
multiple books combined into one right
so for example Krypton Oh makan is a
world war 2 book and a modern-day book
that are interleaved and that's true of
a bunch of my books so this one is a
high fantasy novel that's embedded in a
techno thriller and the Technic thriller
is about a guy who dies and it turns out
that when he was a younger guy he came
into a bunch of money it was that was
that my beer and hitting them the mic
sometimes that happens when he was a
younger guy and he came into money for
the first time he was he signed one of
these wills that gives instructions on
how to preserve his body after he dies
so he'd be brought back to life and and
then he forgot about it because he
didn't really care it was just sort of a
thing he did on a whim but then he dies
unexpectedly and his family and friends
find this will sitting there like a time
bomb and they have to figure out how to
carry out the terms of the will and
because the the deceased is a
billionaire they can't claim that
there's a lack of resources you know
they so he gets scanned the way they do
it is they scan his brain and then later
on he is brought back to life in the
cloud as a digital simulation of a
consciousness and there's nothing there
and he wants qualia he wants something
to be there i I've just made Alvie very
happy by working in his favorite word no
the he you can't your brain is hooked up
in such a way that you know it needs it
needs stimuli it needs in these inputs
and and he's not getting any of that so
he has to create them and he starts to
build a world that he doesn't have clear
coherent memories of where he came from
just fragmented jumbled
so memories and so he begins to try to
assemble a coherent world out of that
and ends up building a world that's kind
of like our world but it's sort of a
mash-up of our world with you know the
Bible and Greek myths and Lord of the
Rings and you know whatever was going
through his head and then other people
start showing up and sort of spreading
out and populating this world and that
is the world in which the the high
fantasy novel takes place and we know
that it's a digital simulation but the
people who live there don't know that
it's as real to them as this world is to
everyone here raising the question of is
it just Turtles all the way down right
right
[Music]